l'école a rich italia 35 ans plusieurs
fois condamné pour braquage
on lui colle au train depuis trois
semaines
ce matin il a pris contact avec trois
individus qu'on n'a pas encore identifié
si mon intuition est bonne à 10 heures
précises
ils vont se payer une banque la case iem
en deux ans un bon signal on aura cinq
minutes pour foncer et bouclé le
périmètre et les civils pour eux c'est
pas dangereux en deux ans et ils ont
croisé aucun flic n'ai tiré aucun coup
de feu quand ils se verront cerner ils
feront pas les confie ce que vous en
savez vous n'avez jamais été là pour
tester leurs canons bon pourquoi pas les
filets et laissez-la plus tard est ce
que ce n'est pas ce que j'ai décidé
capitaine meyer alors préparez-vous et
surtout mettez vos gilet pare balles
demandez de vous aider commissaire
mattei c'est ce que j'ai commencé à
faire avec mono [ __ ] et tout